με έδωσις τις παροχές τ αντιστυχώς δώσε μεγαλήθερι παροχειτους κάτω να αρτούν προς τα πάνω
να κλείσεις τη ψαλίδα να κλείσεις να δημιουργήσει συνοχή μέσα στην κοινωνία να νιώσει ο
κόσμος ότι κάτι γίίναι πραγματική μάλιστα σε άλλους τομίι να πάω σε άλλους τομίς για
να α δούμε ενέργεια έχουμε τα διαφορα προλία τα ενέργειας όντως πρέα ξα συζητήσουμε αυτή
τη στιςμήον μπορεί να πρέα ξάσυ ζητήσουμε το μοντέλο το τάρκετ μότε και το λέω
όμως δεν είναι ή το ένα είδο άλλα εσύ ν διάμεσα πταρεσμότες εσύ για το
μοντέλον της ανοικτής αγοράς τις ελευτες αγορς το μοντέλλον το κλιστν το συγκολπια έσι και
με στη μέση οιχωρέσεις την ευρώπι α άλλες χρησιμοποιούν κάτι α με γα να διαμεσω
μοντελοφαίνεται ότι στην ευρώπη την ίδια το μοντέλλο θαίνεται λέο δεν με σιγουρώς αλλά φαίνεται
μια τάση να αλλάξει το τάρκε τμότελα να μν εν ελευθερια αγορά να εκάτι ενδιάμεσα
αυτά πράγμαα πρέπει να συζητθού στη δημόσια σφέρα επίσυμα όεί να φκαίνει ένα συπουργό να
λεεικάτι νακαι να μέτο συζητούμε να το συζητήσουμε πραγματικά κσούμερα ο καταναλωτίς πρέπει να γίνει
προσούμερο πρέπει αν μποραία παράξει το ρεύμα του πράο δόσουμε τη ελευθερεία να μπόρει να
πάρει τις οικονομικές επιλογές κάσε μια χώρα που έχουμε τρακό εβδομήνταμείδιο λιο με συγχωρίς θησέαμο
δε γίνεται να κρατούμε πίσωπράγματα τα οποία είναι και εβρωπαηγείδιή αυτό του πράμα μου σολε
ότι οκωσούμε πρέα γίνει προσούμερα σε άλλους τομε τατρόφημε έχουμε μια δυσκολία εν έχουμε νέρο
άρα μπορούμε να γαούμε να γρωτική πολιτική όμως εγώ στο αφίσουμε του στην πάντα διότιεχία
αλλα τις ζητήματα απου πρέε ν ληθούμε να ερτούμε να πούμενο καικια είναι φοηδιαστική αλυσία
και ανταμειονεχτήματα τουν τυτοπου τα λογίς στις στα λιμάνια και τα λιπά από που μπαινούντον
τα προϊόν τα απόπρέα εσάγουμε πού πρέπει να κάω